[Music]
[Music]
welcome to a late episode of kos now um
I lost my voice this week so I really
wasn't going to be doing this video but
um I had to get it done
you understand because Linda Carter
deserves everything now I can't play the
music here but if you follow us on
Instagram on Twitter and on our Facebook
community I did a tribute to that Wonder
Woman statue right there also shout-out
to you idiots that was bothering me
about my turntable you know in our
community we have a whole bunch of
turntables you know different sizes
manual alright so for you idiots they
don't know those motorized ones you
don't really use them you like to be
able to manipulate the statues I mean I
can use it I can manipulate this one
because it comes with a remote because
the remote comes with a remote yeah
super certified a lot of my statues are
very heavy so um can't really be putting
it on a motorized turntable that cancer
that can't sustain that uh weight but
the hell with that enough of that enough
of my complaint shoutout to you Danny
my brother shoutout to you lemon aka um
eat this um this statue means a lot to
me this is the last piece for the Holy
Trinity
now on site show me two hungry Trinity's
and if you're not understanding what I'm
talking about the Holy Trinity in DC is
Batman Wonder Woman and Superman
probably not in that order for you but
uh I'm gonna give it to you in that
order because that's how I like them
so now I have both versions of the Holy
Trinity he saw the newer version of
Superman that I did from the Holy
Trinity
he saw the older version of Batman that
goes in line with this Wonder Woman so
that means I have a older Superman
coming up and I have a new Batman in the
Wonder Woman ha ha so you're gonna get a
chance to see those um those statues
just wanted to put this together because
Lynda Carter was at the forefront of my
childhood she formulated how I saw women
strong independent heroic she was at the
forefront of the feminist movement I
believe that she with her persona as
Wonder Woman changed a lot of opinion in
young men growing up because it was one
of my greatest shows so um again that's
the reason why I like Wonder Woman
that's the reason why I have this statue
gal gadot she's alright as a Wonder
Woman
I thought excuse me sore throat I
thought the woman that they had for the
TV show sorry her name escapes me right
now I thought she was a great successor
for the new TV show for Lynda Carter
I thought she embodied everything that a
female Amazon female Amazon's Agra
Amazon was told to me strong robust
because Lynda Carter was a tall strong
woman not saying God the door was the
strong but now she's a little on the
thinner side and a weaker side to me
but again it's all about the celebration
of Wonder Woman so check out the statue
check out the videos and please tune in
for another Care West next week where
thanks to red Titan I'm going to debut
something that's I haven't seen anybody
debut I haven't seen anybody put up and
um you can only get it here at Kos where
I have new stuff coming in Alex at red
Titan thank you so much it's my
inspiration if you like the guys don't
know what a whole rad Titan is I suggest
that y'all go to their Channel and check
them out
those guys overseas is fantastic and I
do appreciate all they help
again this is Kos see you next week when
I bring you that stuff that nobody else
has and remember this is my stuff that I
paid for with my money for my displays
will do women in the background the king
is out
[Music]